when you invite one european great power
to a war it's only polite that you
invite them all normally this would see
wars grow ever larger like the seven
years war or the french revolutionary
wars until everybody was involved yet
the crimean war fought between russia on
the one side and france britain the
ottoman empire and sardinia on the other
was contained neither the austrian
empire nor the kingdom of prussia got
involved despite both being able to gain
something from it which raises the
obvious question why didn't they get
involved why did prussia and austria
stay neutral during the crimean war so
since the mid-18th century the emperor
of russia had been the protector of the
christian people within the ottoman
empire napoleon iii the emperor of
france wanted to increase france's
prestige and please his catholic
supporters and so he got the ottomans to
give him the title instead the russians
protested and placed armies across the
ottoman border and the ottomans recanted
napoleon none too pleased about this
sent ships to the ottoman coast and a
sack of cash to constantinople and they
changed their minds again enraged the
russians invaded the ottoman puppets of
valachia and moldavia this panicked all
of the european great powers who met to
sort out a compromise this compromise
was largely that russia should go home
and just deal with it and shockingly the
russian emperor nicholas the first
refused as such for both britain and
france war would keep the declining
ottomans strong enough to be a permanent
thorn in russia's side so why did
austria and prussia not get involved
well the austrian empire had recently
become a close friend of russia
especially after russian troops put down
the hungarian revolution half a decade
prior as such the russians expected the
austrians to pressure britain and france
to de-escalate or even join the war on
their side yet as you'll know they did
not in fact the austrians were extremely
worried about russian troops marching to
their south it's emperor france joseph
yes he lived that long saw the balkans
as austria's rightful sphere of
influence in fact as the war continued
austria built up its forces along the
southern border which meant that russian
forces had to stay there in case of an
invasion russia soon agreed to leave and
the austrians occupied the ottoman
puppet states to its south it did this
for two reasons the first was to
nominally protect its southern border
but the real hope was that they'd just
sort of be given it after the war and
the second reason was that austria still
wanted to preserve the balance of power
and the reason that it needed to keep
its army in position was that its
leaders were deeply concerned that
russia was going to be carved up which
was a legitimate concern and brings us
under prussia so the prussians also
stayed out of the war despite both sides
trying to get them involved the british
had secretly offered the prussians these
lands if they invaded and also offered
finland back to sweden if it also got
involved the king chose not to this
wasn't out of altruism but because
prussian sentiment for both sides was so
strong that he didn't want to cause
long-term damage to its internal harmony
another reason which kept prussia
neutral was that since the baltic and
black seas were blockaded russia could
only really trade with prussia which was
very lucrative and with that the
prussians just sort of sat the war out
and without them there was no way that
sweden norway was going to get involved
and this is whether those austrian
troops were useful austria's plan was
that these troops were now there to
pressure the ottoman flank and dissuade
the allies from marching too far into
russia the austrians stressed that the
losses france had suffered in crimea
would leave it vulnerable to a war with
prussia this combined with the expense
of the conflict when the britain and the
ottomans were now under pressure to
swiftly in the war and without major
territorial concessions from russia in
the short term austria's proactive
neutrality saw them avoid conflict
whilst appearing strong long term though
it meant that the russian emperors now
sort of hated them and favored prussia
meaning that when the two went to war a
decade later russia made no attempts to
help their former austrian allies i hope
you enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly money maker sky chappelle caution
wolf jerry lamdin jordan longley adam
stalter marcus asner wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod d martin words about books
podcast captain cydog gustav swan marvin
castle common yoon winston k wood gilly
wiggly daniel to be in miss izzette
matthew shipley aaron the white corey
turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski schuenin spinning three
plates and charles the first